it's not just that the average person
the average democrat is just like biden
just ain't up to the task
now even the tacos as dr jill biden
calls them the breakfast tacos the
delicious what kind of breakfast taco do
you like quick let's do it again you
love the carne asada breakfast taco
carne asada too
breakfast taco
bean burrito you like a bean burrito
daphne
steak that is also carne asada okay we
got a lot of red meat eaters in here the
point is
the democrats love their little
breakfast tacos they love thinking that
they can give these people something or
that the latino community that the
hispanic community is just this monolith
that if you treat everyone the same
despite all the different countries they
come from and all their different
backgrounds and desires and all of those
things if we just pander to them in
equal terms we're going to keep getting
these people to vote for us and by the
way it has worked for a long time but
according to this new quinnipiac poll it
ain't working much longer democrats
losing a huge classically reliable base
with a latino vote a new quinnip
quinnipiac poll finding that president
biden's support among hispanics is just
19
right now whoa
19 for the record i like the fish taco
generally a grilled mahi mahi or grouper
uh but uh also you know if if it's fried
it's all right in a fish taco here's joe
biden's response
i just have
one thing to say
they're going here
[Music]
81 million people i'm told voted for
that
pandering disastrous buffoon there he is
he's at some hispanic conference and he
walks up there and plays despocito
i like despocito it's just fine okay
but this is what they do they think of
you if you're watching this
is watching this right now what they
think you are is just a little piece on
a chessboard that they can move around
and give you just little crumbs
and that you will always vote for them
but it's not working anymore and it's
really it's actually quite spectacular
how it's collapsing so quickly